So here's another thing that we know,
that is if we run value iteration,
we get a series of value functions,
say Vt.
If we compare the value function
we have at some time step,
t to the same value function that
we have one time step later,
Vt plus 1, that if it basically
has stopped changing.
If the change,
if the amount of change from Vt, sorry,
from t to t plus 1 is less than
epsilon for all states in the MDP,
then the largest difference between
the optimal value function and
the value function that we get,
sorry for this.
But, by taking that value function,
taking the greedy policy with respect to
that value function and taking the value
function of that greedy policy is small,
right, so we're going to be doing
almost optimal from all states.
And the smallest here ends up being
2 times that epsilon times gamma,
divided by 1, minus gamma.
>> Are you sure that's
intuitively obvious?
>> [LAUGH], well maybe not
intuitively obvious, but the Sing and
Yi proof of this is not so complicated,
not so different from the stuff
that we've been doing.
And you get the 1 over 1 minus gamma
because this little bit of epsilon that
we could be off, could get magnified
over every single step as we think about
this into the future.
That's why we get a 1 minus
gamma in the denominator.
And then 2 epsilon, because I don't
know which side of the epsilon we're on,
times gamma because it doesn't
take place right away,
it's one step from now.
So it does kind of make sense.
But the real important upshot
of this is the notion that
if you can get a good enough
approximation of the value function.
Then you're going to have a good enough,
well,
then you can at least put a bound on how
far off you are in terms of following
the resulting policy from how far
that's going to be from optimal.
And furthermore we don't even need
to know how close we are to V star,
all we need for
this result to hold is, we look at
two consecutive iterations of value
iteration, right, which that we have.
We're running value iteration.
We know what it was a step ago,
we know what it is now.
And so we can compute this epsilon and
that gives us a bound on what if we
just stop now and follow that policy.
So that's a really useful thing.
Otherwise, knowing that
valuation converges in the limit
is not super duper helpful, because
you're never going to get to the limit.
And knowing that value iteration
eventually is optimal, even if finite
is still not that helpful, because
you don't know when that takes place.
So what this is telling us is,
we can actually test on our own,
when is a decent time to stop.
>> So that's cool.
So here's something I just noticed.
If I look at both your 1 and 2,
I noticed that they both would
encourage you to pick small gammas.
>> Mm.
>> Right.
>> Yes, it is certainly the case
that if gamma is really tiny,
like if gamma is 0 then
this bound stays small.
This bound stays small.
It's all good.
The closer gamma gets to 1,
the more things are problematic.
But what do you infer from that?
>> Well, mainly why is that?
Well, that's because gamma really
tells you what your horizon is.
And so the smaller gamma is, the sort of
further into the future you don't look.
>> [LAUGH]
>> If that makes sense.
And so that makes sense then, right?
That if I'm not really worried about the
future, then it doesn't take much for
me to be doing what
appears to be optimal.
>> Yes.
That's right.
Right, it's easy to optimize
over a very short horizon.
And the horizon,
the effective horizon is always
something like 1 over 1 minus gamma.
That's kind of how far into the future
do rewards actually matter.
>> Right.
>> And so right, so gamma closer to 1,
is really looking ahead a lot further.
And that's why it's
a harder problem to do.
It's harder to get things exactly right.
>> So then why, in practice,
don't we always set gamma to be really,
really small?
>> Yeah, that's where I thought you were
going to go, so it's a great question.
I mean one of the things that happens
if you set gamma to be something very
close to 0, is the agent who's acting
in the world acts very myopically.
Very short term thinking.
So, I feel like eating now instead
of finishing recording this lecture.
So I might as well do that.
Right, so you get shortsightedness.
>> I am eating now.
>> [LAUGH] Well that's good for you.
I am not eating now.
I would like to eat now,
but I won't because I'm
sufficiently farsighted to know that
just getting something yummy to
eat right now is going to interfere
with my ability to finish this course.
Because our wonderful and
talented video editor eventually
going to stop [LAUGH] processing
this stuff, and then we're hosed.
So, yes.
Gamma, smaller gamma
means easier problem, but
more short sighted behavior.
Closer to one gamma is looking
ahead more into the distance, but
can make the computations
more difficult.
>> So it's basically what these two
results are saying that there is a trade
off between horizon and
sort of feasibility of solving a problem
in a reasonable amount of time.
>> Yeah.
That's a good way to say it.